how to find a publisher for your book so
i got a great question from my readers
jerry love you guys who wrote in to say
any advice on how to find someone to
publish a book do you have any videos on
this just found out about you a couple
days wow your videos are amazing jerry
clark iii thank you for that compliment
jerry uh buttering up always gets you
onto the show so thank you for that
this is a great question and one that
a lot of people one answer right a lot
of people have a book idea they want to
get it out there they want somebody to
help them market it you realize that you
may be a great writer but not great at
everything else around that you just
want to focus on what you do best so
getting the book deals becoming more and
more difficult the publishing industry
is hurting they're having a hard time
keeping up with online and i wanted to
share my four tips
for you to get your book published
number one is go direct
and going direct is basically finding
all the publishers that publish books
that accept books and and writing to
them and you have a overview of what
your book is all about and you write
into them they usually generally email
address so you can connect with them
sometimes they have
limited dates so they're only accepting
from this date to this date and they're
full up on authors and other times they
they're just always open they say hey
shoot us your proposal there aren't many
publishers who who don't accept in any
format
um but now remember you're gonna go up
against everybody else who's doing the
exact same thing so that that's your
bare basics
entry point is just create an overview
of your book and emailing or mailing out
to all the publishers that you can find
number two is using an agent and with a
literary agent what they do is
dramatically
improve the chance of you getting your
deal they'll look over your proposal
they will
give you feedback suggestions how to
tweak your proposal if you've never done
it before and i'm going through this
process right now it's it's totally
foreign it's totally new and i'm
trusting the people who have experience
in getting big books out and published
and so i'm leaning on their advice to
help
get me that deal now they take a cut of
whatever you make usually you don't pay
a literary agent a fee but they take a
cut or whatever deal they land for you
and so are you willing to give up a
percentage of whatever
you know advance you get
uh in return for getting an increased
chance of getting the book deal for me
it's worth it you know i don't want to
do all that work i don't want to be
emailing all the publishers
and trying to figure it out i'd rather
go with an expert and pay them for that
expertise number three is write great
copy and this
this is so
so so so important because
so many books
are just not that great
they're okay
they're good but they're not great and
if you're a first time author and you
want to stand out and you want to get
noticed the copy has to be great it has
to scream off the page it's got to be
something i look at i have to keep
reading it's a page turner right is your
book actually that
great
and you know show it to friends and show
it to family and show it to complete
strangers and get their feedback on it
and it should be something that is your
life's work
it should be something that you want to
show to your grandkids when it's done
it's got to be that important
it's got to be at that level
because if it's not you're up against so
many people that your chances of being
picked up
are pretty low and if you look at even
some of the most successful books you
look at their history and how they
started even those even though they were
great page turners they still got
rejected
dozens and dozens of times so you have
to make sure that your book is great and
everybody's gonna say my book is great
yeah my book is great so everybody's
saying that right everybody feels the
same way that you do that your book is
great so you've got to take it up a
level it's got to be your life's work if
you only have to write one book ever in
your life this is it and it's got to be
amazing so you've got to pour your heart
soul blood sweat tears everything into
that book
for it to really jump off at me and help
you stand out from a proposal of one out
of thousands that are coming in
and number four is build momentum
the biggest issue now in the publishing
industry is being able to sell these
books right it's easy to produce a book
is getting it sold and so what they want
to see more and more especially from
first time authors is that you have an
audience of some kind you want to build
momentum most authors don't so even if
you have a great book idea the fact that
you have no audience to sell to once
it's out is going to limit your chances
of getting a deal so what you want to do
is start now start building a youtube
audience start building a facebook
audience start building a twitter
audience because if you do that
you're already ahead of most of the
other authors
it gives you a platform
the publishers the literary agents are
going to ask you what is your platform
so they want to know are you an expert
have you gone on radio and tv do you
have a a youtube show do you have people
who follow you on all the social media
networks you have a popular website if
you don't it's going to really limit
your results so start working on those
things now and what i do is think about
what is the core message of your books
you know what is the one word that
defines who you are what's the value
that you want people to to exude what am
i going to learn
from reading your book how is it going
to change me and then create content
around that
so the the content doesn't all have to
be about your book but share with me
things
that make me feel something that are
related to your core philosophy your
core value your one word
and people will gravitate towards that
and when your book is ready to be
launched now you have an audience to
market to so you've got to build
momentum and not just rely on the
publisher to do everything for you
so in summary how to get your book
published number one go direct number
two use an agent number three write
great copy
number four build momentum and believe
it's a great question jerry if you have
something more specific you want advice
on i'm going through this process right
now so i'm happy to help answer it for
you for those of you watching you like
this video you can subscribe to the
channel to see more just like it thank
you so much for watching i'll see you
soon
every week i share my best information
to help you fuel your business forward
in my newsletter check it out below
hi i'm jason j ross fonseca of
risonline.com and i want to say evan
carmichael's newsletter is consistent
fun
inspiring and it's the only newsletter i
prioritize and look forward to period